à quel âge avez-vous fumer votre premier
joint Cindy
[Musique]
bonsoir dans les Français
très mal très mal 25 messages pour dire
que c'est beau indice qu'on passe à la
bonne vitesse
vous avez déclaré 6000 la peur je
voulais simplement faire la musique
j'entendais pendant mon enfance dans mon
quartier voilà effectivement c'est assez
réussi je dois dire alors votre quartier
c'était le Queens à New York où vous
avez eu une enfance un petit peu
difficile avec une mère divorcée des
grands-parents maternels immigrants
d'Italie et vous dites ils ont trimé
toute leur vie ces grands-parents comme
des malades pour que leur fille soit
digne de vrais beaux américains et en
fait
ils sont jamais arrivés vous dites le
rêve américain c'était juste une
illusion pour
ensuite en France dans des écoles
catholiques vous avez été brimé par par
des bonnes soeurs dont vous dites
qu'elles étaient rongés de frustration
et qu'elles étaient extrêmement
perverses avec vous
mais j'ai réussi à me faire virer et
donc finalement il y a un dieu
vous vous dites que les bonnes soeurs
avaient l'impression qu'on vous étiez
leur élève qu'elles avaient été formées
par les nazis tellement elles étaient
dures
le seul votre seul plaisir à l'époque
c'était la c'était la chorale vous dites
quand je chantais avec la chorale
j'étais un ange et je chantais pour Dieu
c'était le seul moment finalement où
vous aviez un petit peu de bonheur je
dirais que ça va ça va alors voilà ça
commence à 9 ans vous teniez les cheveux
en vert pour la pour la Saint-Patrick
c'est première
peu importe j'aime bien faire la fête
à 10 ans vous découvrez le rock avec les
Beatles à 12 ans en première guitare et
là vous commencez effectivement durant
votre adolescence avoir les cheveux
multicolores des fringues absolument
excentriques et vous devenez un petit
peu la dingue du quartier on peut dire
si Lauper c'est vrai quand vous arriviez
à l'école les gens vous jetez des
pierres
de l'université il me lançait des
pierres effectivement vous savez moi
j'aimais bien ces habits vintage mais
c'était pas très à la mode à ce
moment-là et puis finalement quand on me
lançait la première paire pierre et bien
je répondais donc c'était un petit peu
de ma faute et
alors à la maison c'est très dur vous
parlez de votre beau-père en le
comparant à Freddy vous dites quand il
était là on savait jamais s'il fallait
rire vous foncez s'enfermer dans la
chambre
ce que je voulais dire par là c'est
qu'en fait il était une combinaison
entre Dante Vegas et Freddy kruegels
c'est ce que je voulais dire par là il
est entre les deux Freddy ça peut être
n'importe qui à l'époque vous touchez un
petit peu à la drogue au moment de
l'adolescence
je me suis traitée si vous voulez avant
de commencer à chanter et je crois que
chacun fait un moment ou un autre il
faisait une question allez-y j'ai
entendu cette année-là ce rire non je te
jure j'ai entendu sur les raisons
tu as dit le mot drogue
il y a peut-être une piste
[Applaudissements]
vous quittez le quartier du Queen avec
votre chien Sparkle et vous fuyez comme
ça
je rêvais de pouvoir chanter et puis
j'ai réussi à le faire et puis voilà et
donc c'est 10 ans plus tard que vous
sortez votre premier album solo she's
youzoul 4,5 millions d'exemplaires
vendus seulement aux USA vous devenez
une énorme star immédiatement
on peut dire ça d'accord alors c'est
vrai à l'époque vous étiez quand même
une bad girl aujourd'hui vous reprenez
des standards
[Musique]
c'est pas vrai
aujourd'hui vous êtes plus cool quoi
vous chantez des grands standards de la
chanson américaine alors pour vous
rappeler l'époque où vous étiez une bad
girl Cindy Lauper on va vous faire une
interview Badger
[Musique]
à quel âge avez-vous fumer votre premier
joint Cindy
vous avez eu combien de petits copains
dans votre vie Fantine
ate
et sérieux mais sérieux bon
j'avais 15 ans
un petit instant
mais je peux pas vous avez eu 20 petits
copains sérieux et si on compte tous
il faut rajouter un zéro Fortis
combien
de petits copains en même temps votre
record
pas souvent
vous savez pas j'ai essayé mais ma sœur
a été lesbienne dans ses quand elle
avait 20 ans
mais pas moi ce n'était pas moi
que vous ayez eu pour vos cheveux
91 je voulais teindre mes cheveux afin
que
véritablement on y va jaune à l'image
mais malheureusement pour moi ça s'est
très mal terminé et je dirais que
c'était la pire couleur que j'ai c'est
un petit peu verdâtre
Orlando Cindy
non
cette couleur est pas mal la couleur que
je porte aujourd'hui Cindy le plus
longtemps que vous êtes resté sans vous
laver
sa durée deux semaines mais je me lavais
dans un espèce d'une espèce de petite
bassine c'est peut-être pas
avec le recul avec la réponse c'était
une bonne question
à part le succès
[Musique]
petite
dans mon quartier on nous disait que la
cocaïne c'était pas très grave on devait
pas dépendant comparativement à
l'héroïne alors il y a besoin de la
cocaïne certains sont devenus dépendants
mais moi je faisais d'autres choses donc
j'ai réussi à m'en sortir tu comprends
le français
[Musique]
merci
d'avoir été avec nous et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de Inna larditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu